here are this week's taught me in King  Arthur legend of the sword director Guy  Ritchie gives us his rowdy take on the  mythical tale hold your corn cake I roll  them for hiding against the backdrop of  East LA car culture a street artist  hopes to make his dreams come true in  lowriders that is your heritage  don't vocation it with your boyfriend no  I'm just here with my mom when a woman  vacations with her scaredy-cat mom is  snatched kidnapping and hilarity ensues  see with hot in theaters with this  week's anticipation  [Music]  so what's your weekend to get going to  be let us know by commenting see you  next time on weekend ticket  [Music]